معنا من سياق
علم الاجتماع في جامعه مينيسوتا والباحث
في مركز دراسات السكان بالجامحه بالجامعه
مرحبا بك سيد جاك ما اسباب هذه الظاهره في
كوريا الجنوبيه تراجع نسبه الولادات وهي
يعني ظاهره لا تقتصر كما يبدو فقط على
كوريا لكنها ايضا موجوده في اليابان وكذلك
في الصين ماذا يحصل في هذه المجتمعات
عدد من العوامل المتداخله هنا عامل يناقش
دائما هو الكلفه المعيشيه والاقتصاديه
المتزايده لانجاب الاطفال الناس يفكرون
بمنطق اقتصادي ويتجنبون الانجاب او
الانجاب عدد كبير وهذا حصل منذ عقود في
كوريا الجنوبيه والصين ولا سيما انه تعزز
به من خلال مختلفه هذا اولا ثانيا موضوع
الاطار الثقافي لانجابها الاطفال عدم
الانجاب اطلاقا يسمح للكثير من الازواج ان
يتابعوا تعليمهم ان يعيش حياه اكثر رفاهيه
ان يغير وظائفهم كما يريدون وهناك جانب له
علاقه بنوع الاجتماعي اما نقطه اخرى لها
علاقه بتراجع معدلات الخصوبه
بسبب تحسن نسبه معدل
ساعات امد الحياه وكذلك تحسن معدلات الصحه
او همم صحه الانسان
المساله سيد جاك مرتبطه
همم رفض الانجاب ام همم يعني تراجع حتى
نسبه الزواج في هذه المجتمعات
لاسباب اجتماعيه وثقافيه
فيسبوك فيسبوك
وهو الاقرب الى قرارات الخصوبه ما رايناه
مع الوقت هو ان عدد الذين يقررون زوجته
راجع ههه
الطفل الاول ومن ثم يقول عدد من يختار
انجاب طفل الثانيه
وتؤدي الى تراجع معدلات الخصوبه ومعدلات
الولاد
المجتمع الكوري ربما اذا استمر الامر على
ما هو عليه بنهايته هذا القرن يعني احنا
نتحدث عن
انتصار تام لهذا المجتمع في حال استمرت
ديسمبر على هذا المستوى كيف يجب على
السلطات كوريا ان تواجه همم هذه الظاهره
مذهب مذهب بامكانها ان تفعل
من الخوف في الستينيات كان هناك تهديد
وخوف من كثره الانجاب وهذا تعزز من خلال
كتاب
السكانيه ولكن هذا الكتاب قد فهم بطريقه
سيئه وهذا ايضا سرديا الخوف
واطلاق ناقوس الخطر بسبب الانجاب لهذا
نشدد على موضوع تفكير في الفتيات في
المدارس ومؤتم في الجامعه كان لديهن همم
فرص اقل من قبل
وياخذنا الان سوق العمل اكثر من قبل ان
هناك عدد من العوامل المقلقه والموضوع
الاقتصادي والموضوع الاجتماعي الاساسي
هناك عدد شباب اقل يمكنهم ان بطوطه كاليف
عيش او معيشه وطباضت الكبار في السن في
الوقت نفسه يجب ان نفكره بطرق مختلفه
ومبتكره مثل رفع سنه تقاعد او اعاده
الكثير من المسنين الى سوق العمل كمدربين
كموجهين كمرشدين اذا هناك ايجابيات
وسلبيات للموضوع في انن واحد شكرا لك
الاجتماع في جامعه من سوسه والبحث في مركز
دراسات السكان بالجامعه من سيارته